ha ha ha ha look at that that looks very
ha hello that look normal possess little
bug I got a zit on my mouth earlier
today look at that
is it on my lips that sounds like a fun
boy man name one direction you're not
really one direction anymore because
Zayn lad if you're looking for an
alternative names it on my lips I'll let
you have it actually know every tract I
want it hello my name is grace Helbig if
you didn't know that sucks now you know
welcome to my channel if you're new here
and you are not subscribed hi look at
that thing click it and subscribe you
mother
Oh today I thought that I would film a
stream of consciousness yeah that's
exactly how that went
I tried to film a stream of
consciousness video for you and it
didn't go so well so I decided instead
and I would call my Facebook page and I
asked you guys for questions that you
might want answers to and so now I have
structure favorite time of the day my
favorite time of the day is when the Sun
is setting
god dammit I love sunsets I hate to say
this but it's basically like the Sun is
casting a rose gold net over everything
and it's just so goddamn beautiful if we
could just get rid of like noon to 4:00
and replace that with what the Sun is
like from like 5:00 to 8:00
that would be great will you ever visit
Alaska we just landed on a glacier what
do we do now Oh
Japanese cheers to a beautiful beautiful
glacier you glacier are nice yep
probably not where is goose
a little tiny cow in a bed right in
front of me she has been waiting for me
to go to sleep how to get an internship
without freaking out I had I think five
or six internships when I was in college
going to them with complete passion and
complete excitement and apply to the
ones that you really really want and the
thing is I honestly did not I'm very
sensitive about ghosts and if there is
you are hilarious ghosts whatever you
just did was I don't know how you made
that song play from my phone so Justin I
respect your comedy and I would love for
you to leave my house why are you still
awake because what's the deepest thought
you have today six inches new movie
gesture show what's happening here
there's a lot of really great happening
right now
Chester C has a new show that he is
developing with ABC Family which is
really exciting if you guys didn't know
and Hannah Hart mamrie Hart and myself
are working on a new
let it's also very cool and I don't know
how but I'm allowed to say so I'm gonna
talk like this as if it doesn't count
what's the best way to spend my time in
college if I want to pursue comedy I'm
no expert I've no I I can only speak
from my own personal experience which is
that for me the classroom experience of
improv and sketch comedy was wonderful
for me put yourself out there into open
mikes sketch comedy jams if there are no
open mikes if there are no sketch comedy
jams if there are no improv teams create
them for yourself that's what I did when
I was in college my friends and I
created a sketch comedy team and an
improv comedy team and we just tried a
bunch of stuff and it was the most fun
it was really just great so participate
in the things that are available to you
and if things that you want to
participate are not available to you
create them for yourself any cool
upcoming gifts for not too deep I
recorded three episodes of not too deep
today
and two episodes the other day and I
gotta tell you the ladies on the
Internet are king dominating I am so
excited because the gabbie show is going
to be an upcoming guest Lisa Schwartz is
an upcoming guest and Meghan Mattoon is
an upcoming guest these are three
hilariously wonderful ladies that I got
a chance to talk to you for a couple
hours and you guys are going to be
really excited Meghan Mattoon gave me a
teen
tiny copper mugs as a gift for my
birthday to give me teeny-tiny moscow
mule shot glasses girls are great how to
survive when all your besties are
getting married and you were on the bed
binge watching YouTube you can do
whatever you want to do and be whatever
you want to be and on your own timeline
and comparing yourself to all the people
around you it's noise the best-case
scenario and often times I think
everyone around you is doing the same
thing and you're the one that isn't
sometimes that might be the best way to
go there's another thing in like horror
films but there's always like one person
that goes against if everyone else is
doing and they survive or they the one
that dies if you had your own nail
polish color what would it be call if I
have my own nail polish color it would
be called why not if there's any nail
polish brands out there feel free to
slide into my damn so you could be
anyone else for a day who would you be
currently I'd probably be goose yep
how do you trick yourself into getting
it done how do I trick myself into
getting [ __ ] done I think sometimes get
really overwhelmed by the amount of [ __ ]
that I should get done but I have to
remind myself that a [ __ ] that I want to
get done
is really special well there you go
there are my thoughts on a variety of
things thank you to those that asked
questions on my Facebook page if you
guys are not following my Facebook page
you definitely should because I'll be
honest I do not post there frequently or
consistently however when I do post on
that page it is important and so I think
it's worth your while the ghost wants me
to finish this video and I will
subscribe leave a comment like etc you
know what you're doing I don't
anyone else still like bothered by the
fact that there might be a ghost in my
house that played who let the dogs out
from my cellphone